ya que entendemos y sabemos escribir la
ley de velocidad de cualquier reacción
pues vamos a utilizar la ok por aquí
tenemos una reacción en la que el óxido
de nitrógeno con el hidrógeno forman
nitrógeno y agua a una temperatura de
1280 grados celsius y bueno este es un
ejercicio con varios incisos pero el
inciso a nos pide que determinemos la
ley de la velocidad de esta reacción y
como vimos en el vídeo pasado la ley de
la velocidad nos dice que la velocidad
de la reacción es igual a la constante
de velocidad que es distinta para cada
reacción y que es proporcional a la
concentración del reactivo en el óxido
de nitrógeno pero la concentración del
reactivo va elevada a una potencia que
todavía no conocemos entonces le voy a
poner simplemente x
y también es proporcional a la
concentración del otro reactivo
hidrógeno y esta concentración también
va a elevada a alguna potencia que
depende de la reacción y por lo tanto
todavía no sabemos cuál es por lo que
voy a poner por aquí una y ahora tanto x
como ye se pueden calcular muy
fácilmente a partir de los datos de los
experimentos así es que digamos por
ejemplo que queremos saber cuál es el
valor de x que vamos a calcular este
exponente y para hacerlo lo que tenemos
que hacer es calcular cómo afecta la
concentración del óxido de nitrógeno a
la velocidad de la reacción y para a ver
cómo afecta a la concentración del óxido
de nitrógeno tenemos que hacer dos
experimentos con distintas
concentraciones de óxido de nitrógeno
pero mantener constante la concentración
del otro reactivo aunque hay entonces
nos vamos a fijar en los experimentos
uno
y dos porque en estos experimentos se
mantiene constante la concentración del
hidrógeno y tenemos distintos valores de
concentración del óxido de nitrógeno
nuclear y entonces la concentración del
hidrógeno se mantuvo constante en 0.00
20 mientras que la concentración del
óxido de nitrógeno pasó de 0.00 50 a 0.0
100 ok o sea que hubo un incremento en
la concentración del óxido de nitrógeno
del doble por un factor 2 y lo que
queremos hacer para calcular este
exponente es ver cómo este cambio en la
concentración del óxido de nitrógeno
afecta a la velocidad de la reacción
entonces nos vamos a ver la velocidad
inicial en estos dos experimentos y
podemos observar que pasamos de una
velocidad inicial de 1.25 por 10 a la
menos 5 a una velocidad de 5
punto 0 por 10 5
así es que la velocidad inicial de la
reacción aumentó el 4 play y aumentó por
un factor 4 y si te cuesta mucho trabajo
hacer estos cálculos en tu cabeza
entonces pues puedes simplemente tomar
esta velocidad inicial la del
experimento 2 la colocas por aquí 5.00
por 10 a la menos 5 y la divide entre la
velocidad inicial en el primer
experimento
1.25 por 10 a la menos 5 y tal vez así
es más fácil o si no pues puede sacar
una calculadora y listo el chiste es que
esto te da igual a 4 que significa que
tanto está incrementando la velocidad no
creáis la concentración del óxido de
nitrógeno sube al doble entonces estamos
observando en estos experimentos
y de la reacción aumenta cuatro veces
pero bueno con esto que tenemos aquí ya
podemos calcular el orden del óxido de
nitrógeno o sea este exponente porque
sabemos que esta cantidad elevada a la
equis tiene que ser igual a esta
cantidad aunque tenemos que 2 a la equis
tiene que ser igual a 4 y para que esto
suceda x tiene que ser igual a 2 porque
2 al cuadrado es igual a 4 entonces
vamos a poner esta información que
tenemos por aquí en la ley de la
velocidad aunque ya tenemos que la
velocidad de la reacción es igual acá
por la concentración del óxido de
nitrógeno elevado al cuadrado
y decimos que la reacción es de segundo
orden en el óxido de nitrógeno pero
bueno todavía nos falta calcular cuánto
vale este exponente el orden del
hidrógeno
para hacer eso queremos dos experimentos
en los que la concentración del óxido de
nitrógeno se mantenga constante aunque
para realmente poder observar el efecto
del cambio de la concentración del
hidrógeno en la velocidad de la reacción
así es que buscamos dos experimentos en
los que la concentración del óxido de
nitrógeno sea constante y aquí tenemos
dos experimentos en los que la
concentración del óxido de nitrógeno se
mantiene constante así es que vamos a
utilizar los experimentos 2 y 3 aunque
porque la concentración del óxido de
nitrógeno se mantiene constante en 0.0
100 molar mientras que la concentración
del hidrógeno aumenta de 0.00 20 a 0.00
40 entonces hemos aumentado la
concentración del hidrógeno
por un factor 2 y aquí tenemos el doble
de concentración que aquí y qué pasó con
la velocidad de reacción pues pasamos de
5.0 por 10 a la menos 5 a 1.0 pero por
10 a la menos 4 y entonces incrementamos
la velocidad de la reacción por un
factor 2 aunque porque aquí tenemos el
doble de velocidad que aquí que ahí
tomamos el último experimento 1.00 por
10 a lo menos 4 entre la velocidad del
otro experimento 5.00 por 10 a la menos
5 y esto es igual a 2 que como teníamos
aquí y ahora si ya tenemos todo listo
para calcular el orden del hidrógeno o
sea para calcular esta y porque este
factor
elevado a la ye tiene que ser igual a
este otro factor entonces tenemos que 2
a la y tiene que ser igual a 2 y
entonces ya tiene que ser igual a 1
aunque hay porque 2 a la 1 es igual a 2
así es que acabamos de deducir que no
está reacción es de primer orden en el
hidrógeno ok y que aquí en la ley de la
velocidad tenemos que multiplicar por la
concentración del hidrógeno elevada a la
potencia 1 y el listo ya terminamos con
la ley de la velocidad entonces vamos un
poco para abajo y nos encontramos con el
inciso b de este ejercicio ok que nos
pregunta cuál es el orden total de la
reacción y esa es una pregunta súper
sencilla porque ya calculamos la ley de
la velocidad y entonces sabemos que la
reacción es de segundo orden en el óxido
de nitrógeno y es de primer orden en el
hidrógeno entonces para encontrar el
orden
de la reacción lo único que tenemos que
hacer es sumar los órdenes de estos dos
reactivos o sea sumar estos exponentes
lo que hay entonces tenemos dos dos más
uno más uno o sea que tenemos tres el
orden total de la reacción es 3 y ahora
lo que vamos a hacer
es analizar un detalle muy importante
vamos a comparar los exponentes de la
ley de velocidad con los coeficientes de
la ecuación balanceada muchísimas
personas se confunden y se sienten muy
tentadas a tomar el coeficiente de la
ecuación balanceada y ponerlo como si
fuera un exponente y bueno en el caso
del óxido de nitrógeno coincide en que
los dos son 12 pero no tienen nada que
ver uno con otro aunque y el ejemplo que
lo contradice está justo aquí
porque como puedes observar el
coeficiente de la ecuación balanceada
del hidrógeno es 2 pero el exponente en
la ley de velocidad de la reacción es 1
así es que no se vale tomar los
coeficientes de la ecuación balanceada y
colocarlos en los exponentes
aunque los exponentes se tienen que
calcular con experimentos más adelante
nos vamos a meter un poco más con los
mecanismos y vamos a hablar un poco más
acerca de esto porque hay pero mientras
tanto vamos a resolver todos los incisos
de este ejercicio ahora lo que queremos
hacer es encontrar la constante de
velocidad que nunca tenemos que regresar
por acá queremos encontrar esta
constante y bueno pues podemos calcular
esta constante utilizando esta ley de la
velocidad que encontramos en el inciso a
y bueno también utilizando alguno de los
experimentos que tenemos por aquí porque
ahí necesitamos un experimento y no
importa cuál de
todos estos experimentos utilicemos pero
lo que vamos a hacer es sustituir todos
estos datos en la ley de la velocidad y
despejar la k que podemos utilizar el
experimento 1 2 o 3 pero pues yo voy a
utilizar el experimento 1 y entonces por
ejemplo tenemos que la velocidad inicial
es de 1.25 por 10 a la menos 5 así es
que voy a tomar este número y
sustituirlo por esta velocidad de
reacción ok
aquí abajo voy a volver a escribir esta
ley de velocidad pero sustituyendo la r
por 1.25 por 10 a la menos 5 molares por
segundo así es que vamos para abajo
tenemos que 1.25 por 10 a la menos 5
molares por segundo es igual
queremos calcular por la concentración
del óxido de nitrógeno al cuadrado
aunque hay vamos a multiplicar por la
concentración de óxido de nitrógeno a al
cuadrado vamos a poner de una vez el
cuadrado y vamos a buscar por aquí la
concentración del óxido de nitrógeno en
el experimento 1 es de 0.005 molares
vamos para abajo otra vez 60.000 5
molares y luego queremos multiplicar por
la concentración del hidrógeno elevado a
la potencia 1 entonces nada más
multiplicamos por la concentración
en el experimento uno es de 0.002
molares ok vamos para abajo
0.00 dos molares aunque y ahora si lo
único que necesitamos es hacer unas
cuentas para lo cual necesitamos más
espacio vamos a empezar calculando 0.005
al cuadrado por 0.002 saco mi
calculadora y tenemos 0.005 al cuadrado
por 0.002 eso es esto de aquí que tiene
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 lugares a la derecha del
punto y entonces es 5 por 10 a la menos
8 y bueno por aquí tenemos un molar
elevado al cuadrado y por aquí tenemos
otro molar
ok y todo esto está multiplicando acá
entonces 1.25 por 10 al menos cinco
molares sobre segundo es igual acá por
esto de aquí así es que para obtener acá
lo que tenemos que hacer es dividir este
número con todo y unidades entre este
otro número de aquí aunque
ahora que tenemos 1.25 por 10 al menos
cinco 1.25 por 10 al ala menos 5 eso es
lo que estoy aquí significa aunque ya
tenemos esto de aquí y lo queremos
dividir entre esto de acá entre 5 por 10
a la menos 8 y de eso nos queda 250
aunque esto entre esto es 250 pero ahora
todavía nos faltan las unidades por aquí
tenemos un molar que se puede cancelar
con este molar entonces aquí nos queda
uno en tres segundos y queremos despejar
acá entonces podemos pasar los molares
al cuadrado
dividiendo de los dos lados del igual y
entonces nos queda uno entre segundos
por molares al cuadrado que mejor lo voy
a escribir así molares al cuadrado por
segundo
así es que ya calculemos la constante de
velocidad de la reacción ahora otro
detalle que hay que tomar en cuenta es
que esta es la constante de velocidad
para la reacción que teníamos arriba
pero además es para conocemos esa
reacción a una temperatura de 1280
grados centígrados lo que hay está es la
constante de velocidad de la reacción
que a una temperatura de 1280 grados
centígrados y bueno ya nada más nos
falta el inciso de cuál es la velocidad
de la reacción cuando la concentración
del óxido de nitrógeno es de 0.0 12
molares y la concentración del hidrógeno
es de 0.00 6 molares y para calcular
esta velocidad de reacción lo que vamos
a hacer es utilizar la ley de velocidad
de esta reacción porque la velocidad de
la reacción es igual a la constante de
velocidad por la concentración
del óxido de nitrógeno elevada al
cuadrado por la concentración del
hidrógeno elevada a la 1 entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer ahora es ir
sustituyendo estos valores
ok porque nos están dando las
concentraciones del óxido de nitrógeno y
del hidrógeno y ya calculamos la
constante de velocidad y lo que queremos
obtener es la velocidad de la reacción
en estas condiciones
entonces la velocidad de la reacción es
igual a la constante de velocidad o sea
250 por 1 entre molares al cuadrado por
segundo por la concentración del óxido
de nitrógeno osea 0.02 de molar que
vamos a sustituir justo aquí y que
tenemos que elevar al cuadrado lo que
vamos a multiplicar por 0 punto cero 12
molar
he elevado al cuadrado y también tenemos
que multiplicar por la concentración del
hidrógeno que es 0.06 molar que a final
de cuentas lo que estamos haciendo es
sustituir estos números en la ley de la
velocidad de esta reacción ok entonces
tenemos que multiplicar por 0.006
molares
molas y lo estamos elevando a la primera
potencia
y entonces la velocidad de la reacción
la podemos calcular muy rápidamente
entonces voy a sacar la calculadora
tenemos que multiplicar 250 por 0 puntos
0 12
0.0 12 pero 0.0 12 al cuadrado eso no se
nos debe de olvidar entonces es 0.0 12
al cuadrado y también tenemos que
multiplicar por 0.006 x 0.006 y lo que
nos queda es esto de aquí que deberíamos
escribir la connotación científica
entonces movemos el punto 1 2 3 4
lugares a la derecha y entonces es 2.16
por 10 a la menos 4 no hay 2.16 por 10 a
la menos 4 y bueno también tenemos que
redondear estos decimales
y el punto 16 se redondea a punto 2
bueno ya terminamos con el número pero
ahora tenemos que ver qué pasa con las
unidades que hay aquí tenemos molares al
cuadrado y este molar también se eleva
al cuadrado entonces podemos cancelar
este con este y así nos queda
simplemente molares sobre segundo
molares sobre segundo
y listo ya terminamos calculamos la
velocidad de la reacción cuando tenemos
estas concentraciones